[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
i call for the respect of the democratic
principles i urge all the nation
stakeholders to help us in the battle
for the continuity of the state
this country is hurt this nation is hurt
the perpetrators will be taken to
justice
let's keep our cam the situation is
under control
we also don't know whether or not
there's going to be any quick resolution
to the political law situation the man
who is now the interim prime minister
khloe joseph was supposed to be stepping
aside
because jovano moyes had named a new man
to take his place and so
even as they're trying to investigate
this assassination
there's already a very public fight
about who is in charge of the haitian
[Music]
[Music]
government
[Music]
imagine we live in this area close to
the president even when we have problems
with the president we can't imagine they
will kill him like this
[Music]
our working hypothesis is that it is a
sector of the bourgeoisie maybe one or
two or three
combined who hired these mercenaries to
come in and do the job because they are
terrified
absolutely they have the daylight scared
out of them
by the uprising that's happening in
haiti's vast
shanty towns and they uh had to get
jovenell out of the way we think in
order to
be able to have the authority of the
state to
try to tamp down crush destroy this
uprising which is happening from the
shandy towns an armed
uprising i should say a revolution
you